>> Harold: A MAJOR CONTROVERSY
IN THE MEDIA.
NEW REPORTS SAY CHRIS CUOMO MAY
HAVE FORCED HIS OLD BOSS OUT OF
CNN BY EXPOSING A CONSENSUAL
RELATIONSHIP JEFF ZUCKER HAD
WITH A COLLEAGUE.
THE CHIEF ANNOUNCING HIS
RESIGNATION TODAY, AFTER
ADMITTING HE FAILED TO DISCLOSE
THE SITUATION.
UNCOVERED AS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION OF CHRIS CUOMO'S
TENURE AT THE NETWORK.
GREG YOU HAVE STRONG THOUGHTS
ABOUT THIS NETWORK.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS DAY
AT THE NETWORK AND FOR JEFF
ZUCKER?
>> Greg: I WANT TO THANK JEFF
ZUCKER FOR SUPPLYING THIS SHOW
AND MYSELF WITH SO MUCH AMAZING
CONTENT.
SURE, HE COULD HAVE GOTTEN RID
OF CHRIS CUOMO A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, GOT RID OF THE CRICKET
MUNCHER OR DON LEMON.
[LAUGHTER]
HE STOOD BY THESE INCOMPETENTS
AND FILLED ME WITH SO MUCH
QUALITY TELEVISION.
I CAN'T BEGIN TO THANK HIM.
>> Jesse: SHOULD'VE BEEN FIRED
FOR --
>> Greg: EXACTLY, DOM JOHNSON.
I WANTED TO ENJOY THIS STORY SO
MUCH.
I WAS SO NAIVE, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT HE WAS GETTING FIRED
OVER THE WRITINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
OVER THE RATINGS.
NOT A SECRET RELATIONSHIP OVER
TWO DIVORCED ADULTS.
OVER THERE AND TY COBB
NARRATIVE, ALL THE
FAKE NEWS, BUT THIS RELATIONSHIP
DOESN'T REGISTER IN MY BRAIN.
PERHAPS, IT IS A VIOLATION OF
SOMETHING IN HUMAN RESOURCES,
BUT IT IS NOTHING COMPARED TO
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE THAT DRIPS
OUT OF CNN EVERY NIGHT.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN FIRED.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT HOW BAD CNN
GOT UNDER ZUCKER.
IT'S A LEFT WING STATION THAT
NOW TUCKER CARLSON HAS MORE
DEMOCRATS WATCHING HIS SHOW.
THIS SHOW GETS MORE DEMOCRATS
WATCHING THAN CNN.
HE LITERALLY DRANK THE MILK
SHAKE ON THEIR HOME TURF.
THAT'S HUMILIATING.
[LAUGHTER]
THIS OBVIOUSLY IS ABOUT CHRIS
CUOMO EXACTING REVENGE.
THIS IS LIKE A RELATIONSHIP
VERSION OF MUTUALLY ASSURED
DESTRUCTION.
WHEN POWERFUL PEOPLE KNOW THINGS
ABOUT OTHER POWERFUL PEOPLE,
YOU'D BETTER BE CAREFUL.
I KNOW WHAT'S IN YOUR BACKYARD.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED.
THIS WAS A TAKEDOWN FROM CHRIS
CUOMO, WHICH MAKES IT SAD FOR ME
TO ENJOY IT.
I WANTED HIM TO BE FIRED FOR THE
CRAPPY PRODUCT THAT HE CREATES,
BECAUSE IT'S A TERRIBLE, AWFUL
PRODUCT THAT HURTS PEOPLE.
I HOPE CNN STARTS FROM SCRATCH.
YOU KEEP PAINTING OF TURD, IT
STILL SMELLS REALLY BAD.
IT'S A CONDO WENT FOR A QUICK
BITE.
IT >> Harold: I AM A
MAGIC JOHNSON.
PASS TO YOU WHAT.
>> Dana: I FOUND OUT ABOUT
THIS AT 11 OH ONE THIS MORNING.
I SAID AFTER THIS "EVERYBODY HAS
TO WATCH IT "THE FIVE"."
WE TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU WOULD THINK THERE'S
1 MILLION THINGS THAT THEY WOULD
WANT TO GET RID OF HIM FOR A
PERIOD OF THINK THERE'S MORE.
YOU COULD HAVE WEATHERED THIS
P.R. SCANDAL.
AS YOU SAID, CONSENTING ADULTS.
SHE IS ALREADY AT A HIGH LEVEL.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE PRESIDENT AND
IN TURN.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THERE MUST
HAVE BEEN SOMETHING ELSE.
WHEN YOU GO BACK TO CHRIS
CUOMO'S STATEMENT ON THE DAY HE
WAS FINALLY LET GO, HE SIGNALED
OF SOMETHING.
IT WAS ALONG THE LINES OF "JEFF
ZUCKER DOESN'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THAT BRINGS
HIM DOWN, BUT I HAVE SOMETHING
AND I WILL PLAY IT WHEN I NEED
TO."
THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
ONE OTHER THING.
I WANT PEOPLE TO MEET AND FALL
IN LOVE WHEREVER THEY NEED.
YOU OFTEN MAKE PEOPLE AT WORK.
YOU HAVE SIMILAR --
[LAUGHTER]
>> STORY OF MY LIFE.
SPEECH OF YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING HERE [LAUGHTER]
HUMAN RESOURCES ARE WEIRD.
HE SAYS THE TROUBLE HE GOT IN IS
THAT THEY WORK -- HE WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO DISCLOSE IT SOONER.
IF YOU ARE TWO CONSENTING
ADULTS, BOTH DIVORCED, NOT
THINKING THIS WILL GO ANYWHERE
AND YOU HAVE GREAT JOBS, AT WHAT
POINT DO YOU KNOW "THIS IS GOING
SOMEWHERE, WHY WOULD WE TALK
ABOUT THIS IF WE DON'T NEED TO?"
HUMAN RESOURCES IS OVERWROUGHT.
>> Greg: SEE HOW THIS RUINS A
GREAT STORY?
>> Dana: TODAY TO FIND US?
NOAH.
[LAUGHTER]
'S BEFORE HE WAS GOING AT THE
END OF THE YEAR APPARENTLY.
HE WAS OUT.
IT >> Harold: END OF '21.
>> Jeanine: WHETHER "WE HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH LOVE, X
MARRIAGE."
THE INTERESTING THING IS THAT
KATIE COURIC WROTE A BOOK AND
WROTE ABOUT THE FACT THAT ZUCKER
AND HIS FAMILY AN APARTMENT
RIGHT BELOW THE WOMAN THAT HE
HAD AN AFFAIR WITH, AND BOTH OF
THEM ARE MARRIED AND HAD
FAMILIES.
WHO KNOWS WHEN IT STARTED.
I DON'T CARE, BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS AN OPEN
SECRET.
WHAT I FIND MORE FASCINATING IS
THAT YOU GET THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN POSITIONS OF POWER, AND
THEY THINK THEY ARE GOD.
IF THEY KNOW ARE VIOLATING THE
LAW, WHETHER IT'S ANDREW CUOMO
OR JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY, CHRIS
CUOMO, OR THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS, WHETHER IT IS JEFF
ZUCKER -- THEY THINK "I WILL GET
AWAY WITH IT, I AM ABOVE IT, I
AM BETTER THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
THE RULES DON'T APPLY TO ME."
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE SEEING.
WE ARE SEEING PEOPLE COME
DOWN -- THERE MAY BE MORE TO THE
STORY WITH ZUCKER, AND I'M SURE
THERE IS, BUT THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE TRYING TO CONVINCE US
THAT WE WERE HATEFUL FASCISTS.
IN THE END, THEY WEREN'T
FOLLOWING ANY RULES.
>> Harold: JESSE.
>> Jesse: IF I AM JEFFREY
SHUMAN, I'M THINKING "WOW DID I
DODGED A BULLET.
[LAUGHTER]
DODGED A BULLET."
>> Greg: HE GOT OFF EASY OFF
EASY.
>> Jesse: I HEAR THERE ARE
TAPES.
>> Jeanine: WHICH CUOMO?
>> Jesse: I'VE HEARD CHRIS HAS
RECORDINGS.
IF ZUCKER FIRED HIM AND LET HIM
KEEP THE REST OF HIS CONTRACT,
MAYBE HE WOULDN'T HAVE DROPPED
THIS JERK.
I THINK HE TRIED TO FIRE HIM
WITH CAUSE, AND THAT IS WHAT
MADE HIM PLAY SO DIRTY.
RIGHT NOW, AT&T JUST SPUN OFF
CNN INTO WARNER MEDIA.
THEY ARE JUST LIKE THIS.
THE WHOLE COMPANY -- IT'S OPEN
SEASON ON CNN.
DOESN'T HAVE ANY PROTECTION,
LEMON HAS NO PROTECTION.
YOU KNOW JEFFREY TOBIN IS NOT
PROTECTED.
ALL OF THEIR TALENT IS LOOKING
AROUND LIKE "I DON'T HAVE ZUCKER
HERE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO HAVE MY BACK."
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO CHANGE THE
BUSINESS MODEL OF CNN.
"BREAKING NEWS: DOCUMENTARIES,"
AND ALL THE OPINIONS AND FAKE
NEWS CONSPIRACY GARBAGE IS CUT.
THAT DOESN'T WORK AS A BUSINESS
MODEL.
>> Greg: JOE ROGUE IN.
>> Greg: